[Music]
many people gave their time to help tell
the story people from harmony Creon
Gainesville people like Boyce Brown
young chicken farmer who plays John and
Marjorie Morris who takes the part of
his wife Liza's mr. and mrs. Jarrett
played Liza's father and mother and
Paula Hood plays now
[Music]
I'm gonna get this time five six to more
about dogs you check them throw those
out yeah
you can check the wall
well
[Music]
[Applause]
hey morning what'd you get there dad
where'd you get it
grandfather brought it from town
they're gonna pull that charm off if
they keep that up no yours you're
talking that way done and you know it if
we bout to live together they're bound
to spot on this yeah that's real keep on
living here doesn't your father decide
how we're going to raise our children
your mother decided how you're going to
dress pretty soon well gotcha
John please you wanted to be in business
with daddy it was your idea to get all
that money tied up his life savings you
act like I haven't got anything at all
do all the work building all the houses
all the touching you change not too bad
if more folks are in here it's down to
the kitchen and tending our own work
we'd be better off I've been working on
that win for the last five hours man
can't stop for five minutes to get one
then I don't know what well Jeremiah
said you don't save more chickens this
afternoon if you keep that up John Boyd
you're gonna have a bottle at her house
I lost him
just he didn't have anything to do it
yes he didn't let that thing up and
talked him into buying unattested chick
John has as much right to be in here as
anybody well somebody's got to think
about saving the two senses and Lord
knows it wouldn't be used you call it I
call it wait young long I mean leave it
on this farm for 30 years
oh you came home no big eyes is about
chicken raises I can do it again alright
alright that's the way you want I'll get
up John Papa didn't mean it that way
count on you to take sides against me
Liza wait
[Music]
[Applause]
can I help you yeah what K oh hey John
[Music]
how to keep Department well you can have
it I will shout it back on the road you
guys hold on darn thing you know they're
more wage Republican lose your shirt
raising chickens and you can imagine is
this where you want it
Lord is everybody mad today I'm sorry
I've had a bad day
that's okay
watch out Drake the girl and gift a tip
she might cut her head back helping me
that's okay
[Music]
you can't spit and I knew chicken song
okay I'm going
[Music]
how are you going to get home I got my
trunk over you can't drive home like
this no no you can't come on you better
come over to my place and get some
coffee and sober up good night good
night
[Music]
you still up
yeah I wanted to get this press finish I
can't get a thing done the mum's around
she knows how to do something better
than I do I guess but she hasn't the
least idea about style
[Music]
don't you think it's going to look nice
when I get it finished no John
honey honey don't be like that
[Music]
look at that mama first week barefooted
near top this foot leather already she's
gonna be a tough one to handle when the
new baby comes I guess so but I still
don't see why Liza waited so long to
tell me about that oh you still a woman
didn't tell her old man so she couldn't
hide it anymore
one time I kept my condition from Jim I
almost falling out whoa man that didn't
I just I do only natural
we shouldn't have to be seeing the
doctor though I needed that for fall now
guys leave six and a half months to go
yet and no doctor in the world and do
anything about that
I know that much honey but hadn't you
better be thinking of a honey my mom
even showed him a maternity dress and he
didn't even get it well once they get
you married a man don't take noticed
anything but John's right you should see
dr. t-bone any make sure that
everything's all right oh I'll go when
my time comes all right you did not
fussing at me you see now we can cure
you but most people don't have to take
examination like you food handlers do
and that means that anybody that you
might have been with in the past few
months may have syphilis and not notices
yes and if they're married they will
probably make the right pick specific we
got no good husband mind it before I ran
off the next
that's right now but it can be even
worse than that
suppose that this John that you told me
about is married and his wife should get
pregnant unless we find her soon and she
takes treatment it's very likely that
her baby will be born dead or diseased
I'll do anything you say to help honest
but all I know is the fellows work and
we're teaching him about chickens and
they call him John isn't there any way
that you can get a message to him he has
a ancestor
night but I've got to do something I
wouldn't want anyone to get sick or die
on account of me Oh dark head chicken
farmer named John I even know if he is
from this County doctor the girl wants
to help all she can I'm sure of that but
we have so little to go on
and if he's married and if it's wise
pregnant that'll make it all the way
don't your fingers honey haven't lost
with eight chicks out of this batch and
then the fifth week already you're going
to make a chicken grower yet with a few
years of practice hey take it easy honey
[Music]
on the way you act you take license
babies you tomorrow night
woman's got half some exercise gonna be
a boy that game I copied your waist by
now
[Music]
anything I guess I'll be okay
weren't you in here one night a couple
of months ago yep
you know the fellas that will with you
the one named John do you know where I
could find you
little girl John won't find you you know
where to come be the right man you know
come on that's way over there I saw this
other fella
I'm sure he knows who he is and Randy
lives that may be nil but you see this
information that you gave us about John
we have to keep in the strictest
confidence that's amore so you see we
just can't go around asking everybody
even though you do know he's married but
suppose his wife is is going to have a
baby that's the saddest thing of all if
she is let's hope to goodness she gets
to a doctor right away then everything
will be all right if she gets treated in
time you see nil in the first four
months of pregnancies the disease does
not get from the mother to the child in
the fifth month and after it's very
likely then the baby will die no there's
still a chance to take it a great many
women don't go to doctors until they've
been pregnant for seven or even eight
months and even then they don't take
blood tests and no one knows until a
baby comes that anything is wrong I'll
keep looking mrs. Mack every good girl
bye-bye
[Applause]
I'm in there this morning you know we
had lost I'd made out of it fat yes boys
chanting feels like twins
[Applause]
[Music]
below the feet I'm picking up this
morning you told to finish out this
batch or to make $400 easy I want to see
daddy's face when the check comes in
Liza why don't you come into talent and
see the doctor
you're the five months go listen John I
feel touched all right I know when it's
time to go to the doctor it isn't as
though I haven't been through this
before
okay bye
the really important thing about this
multifarious ho testing program that you
civic leaders are helping to put on
candy County it just says now for the
first time we'll be able to help a lot
of our people were walking around was
one of more of these diseases and don't
know it some of them are right in your
own organizations with lung x-rays we
can check for signs of tuberculosis and
Satan maladies blood we can check for
signs of anemia diabetes and and from
the devil inspection we can run many of
our people everything is truthfully
confidential your tests are marked by
number and if they find anything that
shows that you need special treatment
you can go straight to your family
doctor and speaking for the County
Medical Society I wish to urge each and
every member of this organization to get
behind this worthwhile project
[Music]
if everybody keeps working like this
we've attached the county 100% that's
the truth
[Music]
right that's okay
an authority I'll say morning
[Music]
[Applause]
it sounds like you're doing all right
John folks usually have trouble with the
first batch of two brothers the harder
to raise that most folks ain't are you
going home now yeah you want to ride I'd
appreciate it my wife's helping with
this big health program and I can't
leave town before I go back get my
checkup
okay always sorry
[Music]
Rodney is Miss Mac I'll bring in no she
is that she don't across the square the
testing station for somebody else
no no thank you I will die
[Music]
would come on in with me no I got a
couple of things I want to do I'll just
wait all right
[Music]
you mean running off that away you come
on in and get your Sasuke
where's lies and all the fat
[Music]
take this over to the day I have another
customer five amazing route for matters
to know this truth merriment Aloha yes
children
that's of one going on - good hope
you'll have the whole family
[Music]
dr. what makes you so sure well we can't
be absolutely sure until the results of
the second blood test come back tomorrow
but your blood can't get you a high
titer well I've had these symptoms
except Norton airsofter troubleman Lloyd
we're finding more and more kids like
yours often so excited to go unnoticed
by the way I think when you come
tomorrow for the results on this second
blood test you'd better bring them is
Lloyd in with you for tests but hurt
what's this got to do with her sit down
Lloyd we treat a lot of people in RVD
clinics mr. Lloyd in fact we have
information that you've been exposed to
an infectious case of syphilis now over
the to of attend the clinic who had the
tumor treatment know this in fact
there's a strictly confidential
information I can't even tell you who
give us information but whoever did it
did you a real service in all
probability he went to the infectious
stages months ago and it's entirely
possible that at that time wife was sick
for the doctors she's pregnant
near the five months I think and good
lord man you can't let her blow another
week without treatment by that name
isn't dangerous lady doctor but I told
you John I'll go see the doctor when
it's telling what made you so worried
all of a sudden he doesn't all of a
sudden I've been a QA mama here can bear
me out on that you act like I haven't
got any right to take an interest in
your child my dear women's homes with
there's none of your business
everybody hood hi John Liza's woman and
she knows her time no cage and freedom
to be maddening
[Music]
I laughing see fans reason why you've
got to see a doctor
they say I've got syphilis and if I've
got it
but you probably got it too we don't do
something quick the baby might be born
blind or crippled or even dead
[Music]
are you sure doctor there's no doubt
about it
what's your test and mrs. Lloyd's are
definitely positive and the sooner you
start taking a treatment miss Lloyd
there soon will that baby of yours will
be out of danger but doctor both of you
can take the treatment in a few days
time and it's an almost thing I'm sure
you can receive your treatment either
from your family physician or you may
take it here at the Health Department
and my baby when we treat a pregnant
woman for syphilis her baby receives the
same message through the play you sure
no cure can be guaranteed 100% it would
have been much better had mrs. Lloyd
gone to a doctor earlier there's any
good doctor would have taken blood tests
as a part of his regular yeah you're
wasting a fifth month now but I'll
chance it securing her there saving the
baby are still good when do we start dr.
de Jongh boys oh yeah yeah I delivered
her first baby but they want to start
right away so I've sent over the results
of the tests and well it's been pretty
bad shock to the wives so I understand
yeah
well there's Lowen that's the last
treatment first I'd like to see about
every four weeks for a checkup before
the baby comes I don't think we've got
much to worry about and the baby will
come no blow it is blowing we doctors do
a great deal sometimes but we're not
magicians thousands of babies die every
year from this and lots of other
diseases simply because women won't see
their doctors during the first month or
two a pregnancy when they put off coming
until much later as you need we can
still do a great deal but it makes
things a lot harder why did you wait so
long exactly thanks you're all right and
yes you you endangered the life of your
own child
maybe it's thought to die now don't be
foolish lodger there's no reason to get
yourself all upset everything's gonna
work out alright
before we get to probably can't talk
don't tell you what happened doctor said
you said it's been my fault too for not
telling into seeing I know the lies it's
all my fault
I caused over Oh John Kevin let's go
that's right dr. Tidwell prenatal clinic
every other Thursday at 2:00 come along
she's pretty upset about things and I'm
afraid if she loses interest in her baby
it might have these are good I
understand of course you stand around
and we'll take care of it goodbye
[Music]
kitty this is miss Lloyd this is kitty
Kenrick how do you do glad to meet you
there's a young couple in doesn't be on
you
[Music]
God with your Craig Kennedy baby the
beauty
just one teach you how to change dollars
on a dog
[Music]
Red John advisor this is Fred glad to
meet you folks
how do you read laughs it goes to the
clinic - they saved me that awful bus
ride hope you'll pardon my looks but
that heat is about to get me down
that's right you'll get used to the
earth so yes I'd better heats the bed
out of the plant we're putting in a new
era condensing machine Fred these people
have to go home laughs I had the Holy
Family's you cook fun oh sure
sorry don't see it sometimes yes please
- nice where do that and you people
don't fear us we'd love to have you set
on the table now kitty but call me back
later and don't worry
you've got months to go yet all that kid
is beside every time she gets the kick
she thinks your times coming
kitty started buying boats and games
there just to make sure I'm still on the
chicken house again looks like he's
finally over those ticking the way it
sticks out there he makes them pay
doesn't it it's more people around here
would work it's hard to make things run
no leaving papa
he'll eat with me later when it's cool
[Music]
John what's the matter staying out your
9s tonight I know you want to make a go
of these chickens but you don't have to
cut yourself off from his body that's
what I've done utilizing I have an in
your ideas I don't feel that way it was
only like three and that's the baby
isn't born right I'd never forgive
myself but the doctor says it has a good
chance after what I've done I haven't
any rights restaurant I haven't any
right to her son at all right now
whatever is bothering you love the baby
[Music]
it works yourselves never have to take
bad more than 450 dollars or a thousand
dollars coming off next week Kenny came
over to see miles off to the hospital
but looks like the old man's gonna keep
her in the chicken house all day yeah
we'd better go
[Music]
having babies in hospitals are just
plain foolish that bed upstairs good
enough for you to have your evening
before I could they're all they didn't
have these treatments
[Music]
doctor are you sure you've done
everything possible I took another blood
test just yesterday John it looked
alright I don't think we've got anything
special to worry about of course I'll
have to check the baby every month for
three months after it's born
I know Liza's up there suffering to
birth a child that won't be right just
because of what I did
it's happened other people I've seen the
little kids all twisted up John listen
to me
Liza's babies and far less danger right
now the dozens are that are gonna be
born in this hospital between now and
Christmas simply because their mothers
haven't had blood tests there was just
some way we could get women to
understand how important these tests are
didn't you wanted in delivery okay hey
didi done okay
[Music]
right Daniel is life
[Applause]
date of birth September 18 weighs 7
pounds 8 ounces 6 male name of parents
John and lives and Lord it's me John you
know just like you doesn't pick him up
and hold him
Oh John
well I better be getting back getting
late I'll see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
yes sir he's one of the finest baby that
I've ever had the presence of delivery
aren't you boy he's going too fast to
the end and you back in another month or
so I wanna make a final well check at
the end of three months
absolutely nothing to worry about but
it's always best to make sure
[Music]
boy John thanks doctor he's the sweetest
bud you about right to your examination
mrs. Kennedy
[Music]
okay
let's go down to the mermaid day they
make milkshakes that hat okay
that woman always home they all are
about this time
[Music]
[Applause]
all right panting but don't be climbing
on things like to watch John gone
against that boy of his nothing's
another wall fine it's not natural the
way he's acting don't ever play with
this baby like he used to be doing
passed down all the time don't think of
as much as everything him pick up the
child you don't act natural you easy job
got laptop my mama he's always asking
about the baby and besides you can't
expect a man to
well nothing there mom haven't yet
you've got it hot as an oven in here now
I gotta get back get the house cleaned
out before dark
well we'll be eating in another hour
okay
[Music]
whilst the murder time comes it's all in
a half to get it to the hospital
[Music]
the pain
but they just describe as you can we'll
get you that honey
all right we'll have you there so
forgive me face don't kill yourself on
the road I'll stay you okay any what you
mean
you better watch out Brad they gonna
charge eggs for wearing out their full
God John something must have gone wrong
doctor did what any one big the three
weeks yet look I talked to dr. Tippett
when I broke it in you've got a longer
story about things
why's that I had one our boy can you see
nothing didn't go to the doctor right
off the study she found out she was
pregnant my kid yeah when she seemed to
need me most I was so tied up with all
sorts of things that I just couldn't
seem to help to plan all day nobody home
I don't get is going to manage burn yeah
good Lord breath kid gets hold of that
baby there'll be me Eliza
the mama Crawford there's somebody over
there all the time we'll be able to
answer much so you know just talk trying
this boy
magic is me know you can come back man
I'll see you later
Liza laughs it's a girl
six pounds come on ready the kitty came
to it's fun and you should sing Bradley
that one was so excited I thought he'd
pop he was really tough
[Music]
lordy he's heavy
he ought to be he's almost three months
old and dr. Ted will take him the
healthiest baby in the camp he's getting
bigger too young calf
do you think you look like molasses see
the fit name is Jesse John
[Music]